alors à 20 ans vous devenez Princesse
Disney mais en fait on dit que vous en
avez que 17
bonsoir
alors jusqu'à
20 ans vous êtes devenus Princesse
Disney Les Jerry de la mare le conte de
fée va durer 7 ans tout le monde se
souvient de 1 2 3 Mickey Donald et moi
tout le monde se souvient de élémentaire
mon cher Baloo et puis suite à de
mauvais choix professionnels et à des
aventures amoureuses un peu compliquées
vous quittez la lumière des projecteurs
vous commencez un peu à vous défoncer
pour trouver vendeuse aujourd'hui ça va
mieux vous produisez toujours sur scène
et vous sortez un album en novembre vous
nous raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
jusqu'à rebondoir
alors vous êtes né le 26 juin
1963 à Saint-Cloud sous le nom de bougie
darka Esposito alors parents célèbre
votre mère c'est la célèbre actrice
Pascal petit et votre père le célèbre
comédien et artiste Gianni espacito
alors ce qu'il faut préciser c'est qu'à
l'époque votre grand-père c'est enticher
d'un gourou bulgare avec qui il veut
monter une ferme bio et pour gagner de
l'argent pour monter cette cette ferme
votre mère Pascal petit travaille dans
le célèbre Institut de Beauté Carita
et c'est là qu'un jour Françoise Lugagne
qui est la femme du fameux Raymond
Rouleau lui dit mon petit vous devriez
être actrice vous avez un visage de
comédienne et elle va devenir actrice et
on voit tout de suite l'importance des
salons de beauté et des coiffeurs dans
les destins de votre famille nous y
reviendrons alors à 21 ans grâce au film
Les Tricheurs votre mère devient une
star évidemment Pascal petit et à
l'avant-première du film elle rencontre
le séduisant acteur Johnny Esposito et
là c'est le ce coup de foudre à Moscou
se sont rencontrés pour la première de
ce film mais sans plus voilà à bientôt
vous venez au monde et c'est le
philosophe bulgare qui choisit votre
prénom bougie darkaz qui veut dire le
don de Dieu
et votre mère elle vous surnomme Douchka
et plus facile le problème c'est que
votre père Giani Esposito va lui aussi
tomber sous l'influence du philosophe
bulgare et comme c'est quelqu'un de très
entier de très excessif et de très
idéalistes il va basculer dans le
mysticisme total et il va un petit peu
délaisser votre mère je pense que quel
que soit l'engagement de tout un chacun
si on part dans les excès quel qu'il
soit on peut faire du sport avec c'est
n'importe quoi à l'excès et je veux dire
la spiritualité avec ça c'est ça peut
être dangereux alors ça a été pour le on
va dire pour l'équilibre de leur couple
puisque mon père finalement a
pratiquement mené une vie de moi
et comme votre mère à l'époque voyage
beaucoup par jour sur un tournage à
Berlin elle prend un amant un très bel
acteur américain elle se retrouve
enceinte elle a vous tout à votre père
et elle va à l'aéroport pour dire à son
amant que tout est fini et en fait
départ avec lui en Amérique c'est fort
là
c'est votre tante en fait
qui peut abandonner ma tante était une
femme exceptionnelle sans même temps il
manquait mon père et ma mère c'est vrai
que je les voyais pas assez souvent et
bon je n'avais qu'une envie c'était de
retrouver ma maman et on était séparés
parce que c'est mon père qui avait la
garde et
il n'avait pas le bon
heur c'est Carita que vous rencontrez le
destin chez un coiffeur le coiffeur
c'est Jean-Louis David alors ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que Jean-Louis David et
non seulement coiffeur mais photographe
il vous photographie donc pour un
reportage pour votre beauté sur les miss
juniors c'est vrai que c'est très
séduisant quand on a 12 ans 13 ans de se
dire je vais faire des photos je vais je
vais gagner de l'argent je vais pouvoir
voyager
que John Casablanca le patron de la
prestigieuse agence de mannequins élite
vous embauche personnellement et ce qui
fait qu'à l'âge de 13 ans donc vous
commencez à gagner de l'argent comme
mannequin mais je continue mes études
jusqu'au baccalauréat de temps en temps
je manque effectivement l'école pour
pour partir à leur faire des planches à
l'école donc c'était sympa
encore ça l'âge de 14 ans
[Musique]
mais bon j'étais je pense une enfant
dans un corps de femme et bon bah du
coup j'étais pas mal sollicité et puis
j'avais envie d'être c'est vrai de jouer
de ma féminité et là donc vous quittez
le mannequinat et vous prenez des cours
de chant à ce moment-là
donc à l'époque votre mère parce qu'elle
petit vit avec l'ancien secrétaire de
Sheila le producteur de Karen Cheryl qui
s'appelle Imbert i bac et on l'appelle
mémé alors mémé à l'époque donc propose
à Disney d'avoir une égérie qui incarne
la marque alors lui il pense à Karen
Chery la Chantal Goya à Dorothée il ne
pense pas à la fille de sa compagne
c'est-à-dire vous parce qu'il vous
trouve pas assez populaire pas assez
fille de Français moyen quoi je pensais
que j'étais peut-être voilà trôner dans
un dans un milieu privilégié d'ailleurs
on l'a pas dit au départ que j'étais la
fille de mes parents alors à 20 ans vous
devenez Princesse Disney mais en fait on
dit que vous n'avez que 17 oui
ce qui est incroyable c'est que pendant
toutes ces années de mannequinat on vous
vieillissait c'est à dire quand vous
mettez de du remède et là d'un seul coup
on vous rajeunit c'est-à-dire qu'on vous
fait mettre des des chaussettes des
chaussures à brise une barrette dans les
cheveux et quand vous enlevez la
barrette dans les jours on vient vous la
remettre quand on a 17
ans
même 17 aujourd'hui on n'a pas du tout
envie de jouer les gaminatardées
vous vous sentez pas très bien parce que
vous jouez un rôle en fait je vous ai
parlé à personne
et c'est pour ça que en même temps j'ai
vraiment gardé d'excellents souvenirs
scénique du public des délires avec les
danseurs les peluches mais c'était tout
moche pour moi et moi je suis comme ça
verrouillée ceci étant ça fait un carton
un carton énorme et ça va durer 7 ans on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
1 2 3 Mickey Donald et moi alors en fait
c'est un
c'est un succès latino américain que
mémé une bague
[Applaudissements]
approche
le coiffeur décidément je vous jure
c'est une histoire de coiffeur
vous rencontrez vous rencontrez Angelo
di Napoli et là c'est le coup de foudre
là c'est le grand amour vous savez pas à
l'époque qu'il a une femme dans sa vie
et qu'elle est enceinte
et quand vous voulez le virer vous à au
charme vous l'avez vraiment dans la peau
prisonnière du costume de princesse
disney par exemple Didier Barbelivien
vous écris une chanson qui est vachement
bien et puis l'orchestration qui est
faite par mes bagues c'est-à-dire très
sirupeux et tout ça finalement c'est
plus que vous voulez donc vous commencez
à être frustré quand vous voyez quand
vous voyez Lio à la télé en mini-jupe en
train de faire la folas vous dites
pourquoi pas moi quoi ça vous embête un
peu d'être princesse j'étais à côté de
mes pompes avec l'évolution puisque je
devenais une femme et que et que je
restais toujours à la grande sœur de
Mickey donc c'était quand même à vivre
le patron de Disney de l'époque Pierre
sisman lui veut bien faire évoluer votre
carrière mais il vous demande de signer
directement avec Disney c'est-à-dire les
25 mai-bac et ça vous le faites pas
j'espère l'être en tout cas j'ai la
reconnaissance du ventre à ce moment
précis je me voyais pas j'ai
l'impression de partir avec la caisse
c'est de faire un hold-up
Disney et puis évoluer sur une carrière
internationale peut-être ou je sais pas
parce que Disney c'était quand même
ouverture sur l'étranger certaines
choses et puis aussi vous voulez avoir
des enfants à ce moment-là c'est-à-dire
que par rapport à la jeunesse que vous
avez eu dans ce coup vous êtes une maman
faites trois enfants
voilà et je regrette pas parce que je
crois qu'à un moment donné
c'est très important dans la vie d'une
femme si elle le ressent intrinsèquement
de pouvoir voilà
et c'est vrai qu'une période un peu plus
sombre commence pour vous douche car
parce que cette Angelo di Napoli il vous
trompe
c'est un homme
c'est pas le premier non mais enfin bon
donc là vous entamez une série
d'histoires d'amour assez désastreuses
quand même on peut le dire
moi je suis je revendique mais mes choix
parce que ça fait la femme que je suis
aujourd'hui et quand j'ai interprète une
chanson d'amour je vais m'aimer mes
tripes et si j'ai pas souffert dans mon
corps dans ma chair dans mon âme ça vaut
peanuts c'est là vous mettez un peu à la
fumette quoi moi je fumais pas beaucoup
mais je fumais tous les jours pendant
deux ans voilà là vous retrouvez donc
avec trois gosses sur les bras et vous
êtes obligé d'aller bosser dans un
magasin
et d'être dans l'action ça peut faire
que du bien
donc
[Rires]
et puis alors un jour vous faites une
télé-réalité pour TF1 la première
compagnie vous avez vécu ça comme une
expérience positive ou négative oui je
me suis dit qu'est-ce que je peux faire
de mieux aujourd'hui en étant Douchka
Aix chanteuse pour enfants donc voilà
donc j'ai fait ce jeu je suis rentré
dans le jeu je me suis dit ça va être
marrant en plus
produisez toujours sur scène il y a deux
spectacles Douchka chante ces années
Disney vous reprenez votre tube de
l'époque et un spectacle en hommage à
votre père Gianni Esposito et vous allez
sortir un CD qui s'appelle au fond du
cœur en novembre merci merci
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu